the Joe Rogan experience so what do you
think should go on with louis c.k you
mention him I know more about it than
most people because I've talked to Louis
about it
but what happened versus what's being
portrayed is what happened there were
there's a lot of stuff that's just not
true Lackey who's never blocking
anybody's door once and what's unfair is
that he cannot say it he can't if you if
you engage and defend yourself correct
the record then you make it worse
yeah so you're in this sort of purgatory
where if you hear things that are not
true you also cannot say anything about
it
yeah that's a that's a unfair place to
be and also like is everything a hanging
offense my problem with some of the me
to stuff and of course I think like
every right-thinking person it was a
great thing that happened that men have
been put on notice that you're playing
with five fouls and you just can't get
away with a lot of the [ __ ] you use
particular men in positions of our place
right I mean I think lawyer
let's also extend it to the fracking
industry and McDonald's and every other
place in America where probably it's
very prevalent nobody ever hears about
it but there is just no consistency
Charlie Sheen who I'm not picking on I
like him but he got a Superbowl
commercial last year well he did way
worse things and Louie CK way worse you
couldn't give Louis he can't
so people have like let me see guys in a
Super Bowl commercial
that is ridiculous are lisheen yeah can
I Charlie Sheen because no [ __ ] him and
I know but yeah held a knife to his did
he didn't at that time in Aspen wasn't
that he was with the third wife or
something and I seem to remember but
he's done right it's being sued for
giving people a
I mean there's just this litany of
things that are way worse than whacking
off in front of people which is not cool
either of course it's self but Louis
Italy little college Eisen own up to it
and I just think the there where is the
consistency yeah look and also where is
the is it a is it all is everything a
life sentence
Louis is is a horrible person forever or
is there some point where we used to go
yes a person pays his debt to society in
some way and then you know I you know
you're allowed back I I feel I just feel
bad for him I mean I feel like he did
weird [ __ ] that he shouldn't have done
for sure and I think he knows that I
know he knows that but what is the
proper punishment and is and who decides
it well he's definitely working again so
all the people that are complaining and
bitching about her sees no one here
knows he's touring again right yeah when
you selling his tickets to his fans yeah
sure but he certainly can't do
everything he wants to do right and he
can't he can still tour but even if he
wants to do a special boy who's gonna
take him up on that right you know who's
gonna jump jump the law and maybe maybe
the proper punishment is another five
years before you can have a special but
that's a long time well I'm just saying
I'm just pulling it out of my ass I'm
just saying what we need some sort of
it's been more than two years some sort
of me to court yeah that a fair and just
adjusted by judge rose mcgowan presiding
yeah yeah how would you how do you
decide when you know a person has been
punished enough and and what is the
governor yeah but he's got some
hilarious bits about it because so the
problem was I like jerking off and I
don't like being alone right and I
wanted to the rest of the material he
does about it but you know he asked he
asked can I jerk off in front of you
when they said yes he did it it's not a
good thing nothing's good about any you
know
but and he knows it and I'm not
defending him but right people are
portraying it is far worse than like he
went up at skank fest in New York and
people went crazy and cheered and I
reposted the video of it and someone
posted on Twitter one of the rare times
I look [ __ ] you Joe Rogan he assaulted
women ya know like no he didn't know but
he didn't you're gonna can't change
where salt means right he asked if he
could jerk off in front of people and
then he did there's some question as to
whether or not a jerk off on the phone
with somebody I don't think that's
assault either it's kind of creepy not
even kinda it sure he would say it's
creepy but we're not talking about
someone assaulted people like you you
can't just change the definition of the
word because it makes you feel better
about hating someone now I also read but
I don't know if it's true if his
management I think threatened women who
were gonna talk about this or prevented
someone's career from moving because of
this if that happened that to me is
almost worse yes that's a guerrilla beds
yes agree I don't know if that's true
and he's not allowed to talk to
straighten that out well it's not that
he's not allowed to talk well it would
be it was been considered talking about
it a few times and I think he just he
decides at the end of the day it's just
better just keep pushing ahead and right
and his new hour apparently I'm not
advertising for it but from everybody
that I heard it's [ __ ] amazing cuz
all the pain all the treasonous he
apparently has they talked about new
material rocking new I talked about
something to talk about
[Applause]